>> Laura: ANTI-SEMITISM HIDING
IN PLAIN SIGHT.
THAT'S THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT
ANGLE.
DURING THE NEXT SEVERAL MONTHS,
WE HAD "THE INGRAHAM ANGLE" ARE
GOING TO DEVOTE A SIGNIFICANT
AMOUNT OF TIME UNPACKING THE
MOST IMPORTANT POLITICAL AND
CULTURAL STORIES OF THE DAY.
OUR AIM IS THAT THESE
INVESTIGATIONS HELP YOU BETTER
UNDERSTAND THE PEOPLE AND FACTS
BEHIND CRITICAL CHALLENGES
FACING YOU, YOUR FAMILY, AND OUR
COUNTRY.
TONIGHT WE EXAMINED THE
PERNICIOUS INFLUENCE IN AMERICAN
POLITICS OF THIS WOMAN, LINDA
SARSOUR.
I WOMAN DESCRIBED BY
"THE NEW YORK TIMES"
AFFECTIONATELY ASKED A HOME GIRL
IN A HIJAB.
>> I AM A PALESTINIAN
MUSLIM-AMERICAN ACTIVIST BORN
AND RAISED IN BROOKLYN AND EVERY
ISLAMOPHOBIC'S WORST NIGHTMARE.
>> Laura: SPONSORED BY
MERCEDES.
SHE IS A NIGHTMARE, PERIOD.
A RELENTLESS SELF PROMOTER, SHE
REPRESENTS HOW MUCH THAT IS
HIDEOUS.
CHECK OUT THIS ATTACK ON THE
TRUMP ADMINISTRATION WHERE LINDA
STARTS OR INVOKES JIHAD.
>> I HOPE WHEN WE STAND UP TO
THOSE WHO OPPRESS OUR
COMMUNITIES THAT --
A FORM OF JIHAD THAT WE ARE
STRUGGLING AGAINST TYRANTS AND
RULERS NOT ONLY ABROAD IN THE
MIDDLE EAST ARE IN THE OTHER
SIDE OF THE WORLD BUT HERE IN
THESE UNITED STATES OF AMERICA
WERE YOU HAVE WHITE SUPREMACISTS
AND ISLAMAPHOBIC REINING IN THE
WHITE HOUSE.
>> Laura: RATING IN THE
SHE IS EXTREMELY SUBTLE.
AS A COFOUNDER OF THE ANTI-TRUMP
WOMAN'S MARGIN TO JANUARY 2017,
SARSOUR BECAME A NEAR CONSTANT
FIXTURE IN THE MEDIA, SPEWING
HATE AND LIES.
WHEREVER THERE IS A CAMERA, YOU
WILL FIND HER TRYING TO HOG IT
AS SHE DID IN THE KAVANAUGH
CONFIRMATION HEARINGS.
>> [CHANTING]
>> WE NEED EVERYONE TO PAY
ATTENTION!
>> Laura: AND A BAD CHANTER.
SHE WAS ARRESTED DURING THE
HEARINGS THEMSELVES BUT SO WERE
A LOT OF OTHER LEFTIST
AGITATORS.
SHE WORE IT AS A BADGE OF HONOR.
YET SARSOUR WHO CLAIMS TO STAND
FOR THE SUPPRESSED PEOPLE ALL
OVER THE WORLD AND HAS DONE
FUND-RAISING FOR ANTI-JEWISH
VIOLENCE IS REALLY AN
ANTI-SEMITE HERSELF HIDING IN
PLAIN SIGHT.
SARSOUR AND TWO OTHER FOUNDERS
OF THE WOMEN'S MARCH, TAMIKA
MALORY AND CARMEN PEREZ, HAVE
ALL APPEARED AT EVENTS SPONSORED
BY THE ANTI-SEMITIC ORGANIZATION
THE NATION OF ISLAM, INCLUDING
ONE WHERE FARRAKHAN HIMSELF SAID
THE JEWS ARE MY ENEMY.
ANY ASSOCIATION WHATSOEVER WITH
FARRAKHAN IS THE ULTIMATE TOWEL
REGARDING SOMEONE'S TRUE MOTIVE.
>> WHEN THEY TALK ABOUT
FARRAKHAN, CALL ME A HATER, YOU
KNOW WHAT THEY DO, CALL ME AN
ANTI-SEMITE.
STOP IT.
I AM ANTI-TERMITE.
THE JEWS DON'T LIKE FARRAKHAN,
SO THEY CALL ME HITLER.
THAT'S A GREAT NAME.
HITLER WAS A VERY GREAT MAN.
FARRAKHAN HAS PULLED THE COVER
OFF OF THE SATANIC.
>> Laura: OF COURSE A
PERFUNCTORY CONDEMNATION OF
ANTI-SEMITISM OR OTHER FORMS OF
BIGOTRY WAS ISSUED BY SARSOUR
AND HER COHORTS BUT THEY HAVE
YET TO CONDEMN FARRAKHAN
HIMSELF.
LAST SPRING, THE WOMEN'S MARCH
ORGANIZATION CITED THE DIFFICULT
AND OFTEN PAINFUL WORK OF
INTERSECTIONAL MOVEMENT
BUILDING, HENCE WHY THEY HAD TO
WORK WITH HIM.
INSTEAD OF A UNEQUIVOCAL
CONDEMNATION OF THE NATION OF
ISLAM FOUNDER, THEY WROTE
"MINISTER FARRAKHAN'S STATEMENTS
ABOUT THE JEWISH, QUEER, AND
TRANS PEOPLE ARE NOT ALIGNED
WITH THE WOMEN'S MARCH
PRINCIPLES."
TO QUOTE ANOTHER WELL-KNOWN
ANTI-SEMITE, THE CHICKENS ARE
COMING HOME TO ROOST.
THE MAIN FOUNDER OF A WOMAN'S
MARCH, TERESA SHOOK, WANTS THE
SARSOUR, MALLORY, PEREZ TRIO TO
STEP ASIDE.
EVEN THE NASTY TRUMP HATER
ALYSSA MILANO WAS LESS THAN
CHARMED.
SHE IS THREATENING TO BOYCOTT
THE NEXT WOMEN'S MARCH COMING UP
IN JUST A COUPLE MONTHS UNLESS
SARSOUR AND COMPANY LEAVE THE
ORGANIZATION.
MY QUESTION IS, WHAT TOOK THEM
SO LONG?
SARSOUR OF COURSE FEIGNED AN
APOLOGY BUT SHE IS NOT BACKING
DOWN FROM HER HARSH ATTACKS ON
JEWS.
JUST A FEW WEEKS AGO ON
FACEBOOK, SHE SLAMMED FOLKS WHO
MASQUERADE AS PROGRESSIVES BUT
ALWAYS CHOOSE THEIR ALLEGIANCE
TO ISRAEL OVER THEIR COMMITMENT
TO DEMOCRACY AND FREE SPEECH.
THE PHRASE "ALLEGIANCE TO
ISRAEL" IS A FAVORITE AMONG THE
ANTI-SEMITIC SET.
TO HIS CREDIT, CNN'S JAKE TAPPER
AT WAS ALL OVER SARSOUR LAST
SPRING AFTER THEY WOMEN'S MARCH
WISHED A COP KILLER FUGITIVE WHO
FLED TO CUBA HAPPY BIRTHDAY.
THE VENOMOUS SARSOUR RESPONDED
WITH "JAKE TABBERT JOINS THE
RANKS OF THE ALT-RIGHT TO TARGET
ME ONLINE."
ASIDE FROM THE TWITTER TAKEDOWN,
MEDIA OUTLETS INCLUDING CNN WERE
RESPONSIBLE FOR ELEVATING
SARSOUR TO CULT LIKE STATUS.
SO DESPERATE TO SMASH ALL THINGS
TRUMP, THE LEFT WAS ONLY TOO
HAPPY TO OFFER THIS INCENDIARY
FIGURE IN A PLATFORM ORGANIZE.
>> WERE COMING BACK OUT AND
ANNOUNCING TO THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE TO JOIN US AROUND THE
COUNTRY AND IN WASHINGTON, D.C.,
ON JANUARY 19, 2019.
WE ARE OUTRAGED THAT WE ARE
TALKING ABOUT AND PUTTING
VICTIMS ON TRIAL AND TALKING
ABOUT DR. FORD IN THE WAY IN
WHICH SHE WAS TREATED AT THE
HEARING.
>> Laura: UNREAL.
TODAY SOME GOOD NEWS.
CNN DUMPED MARC LAMONT HILL
AFTER HE DELIVERED A SPEECH AT
THE U.N. THAT SEEM TO CALL FOR
WIPING THE STATE OF ISRAEL OFF
THE MAP.
HIS ASSOCIATION WITH THE NETWORK
WAS ESPECIALLY IRONIC GIVEN THE
NETWORK'S NEW SERIES AT CNN
ABOUT THE RISE OF ANTI-SEMITISM
HERE AND ABROAD.
SARSOUR OWES HER PUBLIC PROFILE
TO A PRESS THAT HAS GONE OUT OF
ITS WAY TO COVER FOR HER RATHER
THAN ACTUALLY COVER HER TRUE
MOTIVES AND ALLEGIANCES.
THEY MADE EXCUSES FOR SARSOUR
BECAUSE SHE'S A WOMAN.
SHE'S MUSLIM.
AND SHE'S A HARSH CRITIC OF THE
PRESIDENT.